we mentioned Twitter are either of you
on Twitter and if you are
what's your regular ard name to you I'm
not on Twitter so I don't get that out
of the way we're way that didn't that's
no no no I don't I read Twitter for for
some news but I don't really tweet very
often I have a Facebook page that I've
been tallying alter-egos a lot and
that's you know it's been kind of fun to
hear people's reactions but I don't
really do I don't think either of us do
a whole lot of like self promoting in
that arena do you think that's part of
an actor's job in terms of being a part
of a project are they there just to be
on set and then when they're done walk
away or continue with promoting it I
think obviously we you know we enjoy
promoting that's what we're here so I
don't I do not enjoy
well promoting you're not very good at
it I don't think it's part of the
actor's job to be honest I think it is
it is now it's expected of actors a lot
more and I and I think that it's
understood to be part of an actor's job
so in saying that technically now that
it's part and parcel of when you sign on
to do a movie you are expected to be
doing a certain amount of promotion me
personally though I don't think that's
the way it should be and I don't think
it as part of an actor's job I think an
actor you primarily is there to be
performing and do a great job and on set
and then that's when your job ends
you're like mr. pink in Reservoir Dogs
I don't believe in tipping yeah it's for
the birds you know I mean it's just
thinking about that scene just today
there's no similarity what I'm saying
right now it's very so no that's not
nothing because you look like mr. Fogg
except my weird
look like mr. penguin everything a lot
like future city and they ventilate
moaning tipping is very very important
thing to do not promoting though on the
other hand he promotes like crazy never
tips I'm not - never won't I loaded it
down for anybody I think that you know
if you do a studio film it's it's in
your contract you have to do you know
I'm not debating it you're expected to
do it and it is in your contract I'm
just saying I don't think it is part of
an actor's job dear ethically speaking
but it is in reality totally part of
your job well I mean everyone wants
their film to be to be exposed and to
you know to get out there and I think
that actors nowadays have how much good
you think promoting does for an actor go
to for a film I don't or you're watching
TV and you see this interview on TV do
you go out and watch alter egos because
of you and me sitting on the couch well
I think that I'm probably yeah maybe
more so than if I see if I don't see
that I kind of feel like it's just like
it said you guys probably know better
than me but I think it's sort of just a
self-supporting industry or it's just
people are you know where actors we're
looking to self-promote and to a certain
extent you guys need someone to
interview and you decipher we also work
together and and and basically take up
space in this world but we don't I don't
know how much good this does for the
film well I think that if you if you see
if there's an actor that promotes a film
it makes you think oh you know what I
like that actor he really likes this
film I'm probably gonna go see it
because no genuinely
I mean you I'm not allowed to you know
if I'm Johnny Depp for example mm-hmm
and I go on some late-night talk show if
it's gonna have a wide audience of
people watching it I'm not allowed to
say I hated this movie so it's
disingenuous everybody says I love the
movie so good no one's you paying
attention it's just know what you can
kind of tell you can tell when an actor
likes or doesn't like the film you know
make it even thinking you can come by
that rationale then if you're expecting
an action to promote and he doesn't
actually like the movie then he's doing
the filming disservice by going and
promoting it I think that that's why
sometimes they
an actor didn't have to do that or a
big-time actor may say look I don't like
this film I'm not going to be very good
at promoting it so don't ask me to go do
these these interviews I mean look at me
American trio how often you seen him do
interviews and things like that very
very rarely and I think I don't know but
I imagine it's because he hates Sheldon
yes no he doesn't do me terrible and
it's not gonna help but I don't know uh
yeah interesting I mean I always think
that when you reach a certain level of
Fame that if you really hate going out
and doing a top judging everything you
can finally just say I'm not doing a
tank you and nobody cares because you're
a big enough name at that point I'm
anyways but every studio would one you
know even the bigger they figure the
better they want that personal no no
doubt about it I know they all want that
I think that's one of the reasons Johnny
Depp is to make a star that he is is his
willingness to just be remote promote
promote promote promote exactly do you
feel though that beefing up your social
media might help in some sense it's like
casting directors and even Studios are
looking at people's Twitter following
and even like people are paying to beef
up that energy meter wow this is amazing
that's like Jones how do I get them what
do I do I pay to beef up the star meter
who I pay IMDB or do I pay like thousand
wanted to go and click on my face no you
got it's like that meters is I think
five people that like look you up online
or at certain uncertain engines and
stuff and so I think it interesting
you